[MUSIC]
Thanks to all of you for being here.
Welcome back to Stanford.
these, these reunions are great, aren't
they?
[LAUGH] I don't know how many of you might
have thought you would be back here
in 2014, as you were graduating and going
off, to, pursue lives post-Stanford.
But we are all delighted, that you're back
here today.
Especially, back here to talk about the
new longevity, that we are experiencing.
The plan for this afternoon is that I'm
going to talk for a bit,
try to give a, a, a broad overview of
longevity.
What's happening, what's not happening say
a little bit about why aging may feel so
hard at this point in history for a lot of
us.
And then what I'm gonna do is to turn
things over to two of my colleagues.
Who are senior scholars, senior research
scholars at the Stanford Center on
Longevity and they are going to talk some
about mobility and
the critical role of being mobile and fit
and able to
navigate the world is so important and the
work that we're doing in that realm.
And Martha Devee who leads, is a senior
research scholar and
leads the division on financial security
at the Center on Longevity.
Both Martha and Ken came to the center
about five years ago, 2009.
And they brought with them deep expertise,
outside of academia.
Martha had been working in Silicon Valley
and largely in tech and
financial services and Ken Smith is an
engineer and he had been working
at Intel prior to that and aerospace and a
number of other engineering fields.
And by design, the Stanford Center on
Longevity brings in people who know how to
make things happen outside of the
university to work with
our faculty affiliates, to try to speed
the efficiency with which we
can translate the kinds of things that we
are learning, at Stanford and
research laboratories around the
university to actual changes and
products that can occur, to improve life.
So that is the plan.
We're gonna leave a lot of time at the end
for questions, and so
I will at the end after Ken and Martha
have spoken for a few minutes.
The three of us are gonna come back up
here and
try to have a conversation with you all in
the room.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, people are living longer.
[LAUGH] Societies are getting grayer and I
know you know that.
We read about it in the newspapers nearly
everyday.
Some article on aging and aging societies.
We hear about it on our television sets on
a regular basis on the news.
And sometimes I worry that we hear about
it so
much that we've come to accept this with a
kind of a complacency.
You know, you sort of say, what could be
slower and steadier, and
maybe drearier, than getting older, and
older, and older?
And I think we're thinking about this
often, outside of the historical context,
a remarkable historical context, in which
this aging thing is happening.
So, what I wanna do, just for a minute, is
to kinda zoom out, and
consider the point in history, where we
are living.
Let me start by saying that more years
were added
to average life expectancy in the 20th
century than all years added
across all prior millenia of human
evolution combined.
In a blink of an eye, in historical terms,
we nearly doubled the length of the lives
that we are living.
17th century philosopher Thomas Hobbs had
it right,
he described life as nasty, brutish and
short [LAUGH] and throughout most of human
evolution, that's exactly what it was.
We don't know what life expectancy was as
we were or
our ancestors were evolving on, on the
African savannah.
Estimates go from 18 to about 20,
[LAUGH] but there's considerable agreement
that life expectancy was short.
Now evolution acted on age on life
expectancy in these early years.
It acted in a way that evolution acts, a
snail like pace.
And the average length of life got a
little bit longer, little bit longer,
little bit longer.
By the mid-1800's life expectancy in the
United States
had reached the mid-30's and by 1900 life
expectancy was 47.
At the end of that same century life
expectancy was 77 and today, it's 79.
And still going up.
This change is not finished with us yet.
In recent years, three months are being
added to
average life expectancy at 65 every year.
So every four years we're getting an
additional year of life at 65.
Now, across that very same period that
life expectancy was going up so
dramatically.
Fertility rates drop precipitously, by
half.
So in 1900 the average number of children
born to an American woman was 4.2.
Like the decimal points.
And by the end of the century that number
went to 2.1.
And the combination of increased life
expectancy, people living longer,
and having few children resulted in aging
societies.
So we could have had longer lives, without
aging societies.
We would have much larger populations, but
these two phenomena together,
reorganized, redistributed, age, in the
population.
So, in, in 1900, 4% of the population in
this country was over 65.
Today 14% is over 65.
And I have to say, I had to update that
percentage from last year which was
13% [LAUGH] so these numbers just keep
bumping up, you've gotta stay current.
14% today, and it will go to 20% by 2030,
20% of the population will be over 65.
Now we remain the young kid on the block,
compared to other developed nations that
are already much older.
In Japan, 16% of the population today is
over 65,
in Japan, 20% of the population is over 65
today and
by 2030 that number will increase to 28%.
Now these numbers are game changers for
really every aspect of life as we know it.
education, work, retirement, families,
politics,
all are going to change as a function of
this shift from being young populations,
young societies, to aging populations.
Now just to be clear as to so, what, what
is happening here,
let me distinguish an increase in life
expectancy from an increase in life span.
Often we hear about aging societies and
increases in life span,
potential increases in life span, all
bundled together.
But these are very different phenomena.
And to the best of our knowledge,
life span has not increased across the
years of human evolution.
What changed was life expectancy.
The average length of life, but not the
capacity.
Now, ever since I've been in this field,
there have been voices
talking about the possibility of removing
the cap on human mortality.
In fact, humans have been searching for
the Fountain of Youth ever since we
realized we were mortal.
[LAUGH] We used to sail off in ships and
now we turn to laboratories, but
there's still a lot of people seeing if
they can solve that conundrum.
Death.
[LAUGH] Generally those voices have come
from the scientific fringe.
But you know, in these parts when Google
gets interested [LAUGH] we all take note.
And Google has now as many of you know
formed a new company called Calico and
hired Art Levinson the former CEO of
Genentech to run it.
And let me say also that there are a lot
of very distinguished biologists
who are thinking they might be able to
find a way to increase life span
through some sorts of scientific and
medical advances in the 21st century.
Now, these remain promises at this point
in time or guesses, hypothesis.
It has not happened yet.
But increasingly, people are beginning to
consider the possibility
that life expectancy could actually
increase dramatically, substantially,
beyond the current ages, because of some
potential of science.
Now when we think about lifespan, how long
it's possible for an organism to live and
humans we have to acknowledge that this
remains a theoretical concept.
We don't know what lifespan is in humans.
We know what it is in earthworms, we know
what it is in gypsophila.
Where we can observe, you know, in petri
dishes and so
on, their, their, their lifespans, but,
you know, this would, this, this is just
a, a, a, a concept in humans.
We don't know.
It would mean, what would happen, how long
would life be if we found cures for
all of the diseases, we removed all of the
environmental toxins,
we have reduced accidental deaths to near
zero,
we would be able to see what life's span
would look like, but
when guesses are being bandied about, we
know that 120 is possible.
122 is possible because the first woman,
ever to have been documented [LAUGH] as
the longest
lived person ever died at the age of 122
in 1997.
Jeanne Loise Calment was a French woman
who lived in the French city of Arles.
And I like to tell people about her
because she's pretty inspirational.
I mean this is a woman who to very,
very advanced ages, to very shortly before
her death was sharp, engaged,
funny, she made a rap album when she was
in her 90's.
[LAUGH] She played herself in the movie
Vincent and
Me which was about Vincent van Gogh.
She had actually met him, she was the only
person on the planet who had
actually known him, [LAUGH] and that made
her the oldest actress of all time.
[LAUGH] She was interviewed a lot as you
might imagine and and
she was very funny, but one, one,
one journalist had posed the question,
what sort of a future do you envision?
And Calment thought about it and said, a
very short one.
[LAUGH].
[BLANK_AUDIO]
But my favorite Calment story hands down
concerns a property deal that she
made at the ripe old age of 90.
Kalment owned her own home as I mentioned
in the French city of Arles.
And it was a family home.
She'd lived in it most of her life.
And she had every intention of living out
her life in this home.
But there was this lawyer.
A young guy, he was 47 years old.
He really wanted to buy the house.
And he had made her offers over the years.
And she'd turned them all down.
And he would show up and he'd make her a
better offer, and she'd turn him down, and
that was the way things went for a long
time, and
then one day he shows up on her doorstep
and he says I've got a deal for you.
I will pay you $400 a month for
the rest of your life if you will deed the
house to me on your death.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[LAUGH]
She thinks about it.
She says okay.
And they draw up a contract and over the
next 30 years.
>> [LAUGH].
>> This fellow paid her more than three
times the value of her home.
>> [LAUGH].
>> She outlived him by two years [LAUGH].
[LAUGH].
>> He died at 77.
They'd become friends over the years,
though.
And they were overheard chatting at, at,
at,
at her, 120th birthday party, shortly
before he died.
And, [LAUGH] she had turned to him at one
point, and
said, you know, we all make bad deals.
[LAUGH].
So that's what 122 can look like.
But an increase in life span, increasingly
more people living to these very, very,
very advanced ages had nothing to do with
these changes.
The changes that we are living through
today.
These changes reflect life expectancy
changes.
Differences in the odds of making it to
old age,
differences in the average length of life.
And essentially what has happened, is that
these population pyramids,
that we learned about in school, do you
remember the population pyramids?
Cuz when I lecture younger people today
they don't.
You're very young.
[LAUGH] So population pyramids,.
Represented the, the populations in every
country on the globe as recently as 1950.
And they also, by the way, represent most
species.
Basically, you have many at the bottom,
young ones born in a population and
then the distribution has winnowed to a
tiny peak at the top.
That's the way populations have
historically been shaped.
And what has been happening over the years
is that these pyramids in the developed
world are being reshaped into rectangles.
And if you're the kind
of person who can get chills from
population statistics [LAUGH] my people.
[LAUGH] These are the ones that should do
it because what this means is that for
the first time in history, the vast
majority of babies born
in the developed world are having the
opportunity to grow old.
And this is an astounding cultural
achievement.
We dramatically reduced premature death,
essentially so
that now most people can grow old.
How'd we do this?
[LAUGH] well, the short answer is science
and technology.
This remarkable increase in life
expectancy is really a product of culture.
And by culture I'm referring to the
crucible that holds science and
technology and large scale behavioral
practices and, and social norms.
We applied science and technology and we
changed the way we
live in order to improve the health and
well-being of the population.
Our ancestors in the 20th century
discovered the causes of diseases and
how they were spread.
And then they instituted grand public
health programs to
vaccinate children against diseases that
they would never have to suffer.
They didn't stop there.
They pasteurized milk, purified the
waterways, and
these changes had magnificent influences
on health.
They also implemented the systematic
disposal of waste, garbage collection
which again significantly, substantially
reduced the spread of contagious disease.
And some historians write that you have
your garbage collectors to thank as much
as your physicians for this increase in
life expectancy.
We didn't stop there with science and
technology.
As fertility rates fell we came to invest
more in children.
We had fewer of them and we said we needed
to make bigger investments and
we established public education in every
state in this great nations so
that all children could learn how to read
and write, not just the privileged few.
And today, at some point in adulthood,
education becomes a better predictor of
life expectancy than age.
A stunning, stunning development.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So here we are.
Living in a point in history where four,
five and conceivably six generations could
be alive at the same time.
You know, contrast this with a 100 years
ago.
A 20-year-old in 1900 was less likely
to have a living mother than a 20-year-old
today is of having a living grandmother.
And a demographer at Berkeley predicts
that by 2030, the majority of children
in the United States will not only have
two living biological parents but
a full compliment of grand parents and
great grand parents.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We need to make this the best thing that
ever happened to children.
We need to turn this demographic change
into a resource.
But, we can not be doing that yet as a
society.
Instead, when we think about aging
societies,
these days, mostly, we're hearing about
fear, concern.
About older people absorbing all of the
resources in society and
leaving the young ones on their own.
We're hearing about disorders like
osteoporosis, osteopenia,
arthritis, as limiting people's functional
ability.
Some of you will have read Zeke Emmanuel's
article in the Atlantic recently which is
titled, I hope I die by 75.
[LAUGH] Where he's saying he doesn't want
to live a disabled life.
We're hearing that people haven't saved
enough for
retirement and so we're going to see
poverty rates increase.
We're seeing populations and work forces
in many old, rich countries shrink,
while we see the populations in young,
poor countries expand.
Now these are, these are real challenges
that need to be addressed.
As I said, I think they really reflect the
mismatch between the length of
lives that we're living and the culture
that guides us through life.
And the Stanford Center on Longevity was
founded in order to
redesign culture so that it supports
people all the way through.
I mean essentially, we think that the
culture we live in today, which evolved
around lives half as long, does a pretty
good job of supporting people up to 50.
And then it kinda stops.
Now, a lot of people do very well after
50, but they're far fewer guide points and
norms and societal resources that, that
are helping people structure their lives.
And humans are creatures of culture.
We listen to culture to tell us when to
get an eduction, when to marry,
when to have children, when to retire.
And we need to change that mismatch and we
need to do it with considerable speed.
As we learn about aging, we're finding
that the malleability, the plasticity,
the potential for people to age well is
greater than ever previously imagined.
Science is beginning to catch up with
this, but
I made this slide to try to summarized all
the research on aging in a single image.
[LAUGH] And I think this really is the
model that's guiding most
research on aging, you know, we say, well,
there, here's a variable?
I'll compare younger people to older
people, and older people won't do so well.
And that's not a bad question to ask,
anybody here, you know,
over the age of 50 knows that there's a
lot not to like about aging these days.
So, we do want to seek knowledge about the
problems and a better understanding.
But if you only ask questions about what
goes wrong,
you generate a literature about what goes
wrong,
and we need to begin to ask questions
about what may go right.
What may facilitate and help people's
aging.
And the more that we learn,
the more empirical data that are
collected, the more we see that
this model is not the typical model that
represents most aging trajectories.
So let me tell you just a very little bit
about a range of
different topics that have been studied to
point out the, the, the,
the, these, the nuances that we are
beginning to identify.
We have learned over the last 50 years
that processing speed, learning,
taking in new novel situations and
information, tends to decline steadily.
And it begins at the ripe old age of 23.
[LAUGH] And we see this kind of steady
downward slope.
That's certainly been the traditional way
of characterizing learning, and
the ability to learn.
It's not that people can't learn, as they
get older, but
it's a little more degraded.
A little slower, takes a little bit more
time.
This has been the focus of most of
research on cognitive aging.
But just as sure, knowledge across the
same years is going up.
So new learning may take a little bit
longer, but people have lived longer and
they have more time to learn.
And so we see knowledge trajectories go
up.
And I want to point out that this line has
to be a great underestimate of knowledge,
because it's given or tapped by test of
general cultural knowledge,
by vocabulary, or, knowledge, answers to
questions, you know,
like what is the capital of Afghanist-,
in Afghanistan.
You know, I mean, those are the kinds of
questions that people are asking.
They're not being asked questions about
expertise in the areas in which
they have developed great depth of
knowledge.
So we're underestimating this knowledge,
this knowledge potential, undoubtedly.
And in very recent years, we've begun even
to challenge the red line.
That were seeing this steady decline.
And here's why.
Because we've been running studies long
enough now to have longitudinal databases
on individuals who have been tested
repeatedly throughout mid to late life.
And they've been studied long enough to
know that some people have gone
on to develop Alzheimer's disease.
And these are data from David Bennett's
laboratory, from
a longitudinal study he ran.
And he's been measuring this processing
speed thing that goes down so gradually.
And he removes people who got Alzheimer's
disease and
he recalculates what that decline looks
like, and looks like the red line.
In the blue line, those people,
these are not people who have symptoms of
Alzheimer's disease, any sort of sign, but
they're people who are gonna go on to
develop it.
And they're showing a steep decline, but
a much more modest decline in those
individuals who will remain healthy.
And if there's any good news about
Alzheimer's disease and there is not much,
it's that the majority of people won't
ever suffer from the disease,
even into the 90s, 60 some odd percent of
people will not get Alzheimer's disease.
So even though the rates go up it's not
like it's inevitable.
So you pull those two things apart.
My point is, it's possible that we come up
with these slopes, these pretty slopes,
because we've been compounding, inflating
disease with normal cognitive aging.
And it might help us understand why, it
sure seems like there a lot,
an awful lot of older people who are very
quick on the uptake.
They likely are, the majority.
So, we're beginning to have to even
rethink some of
these long held beliefs about cognition
and aging.
Well, there's a really good story about
emotion and aging.
It looks like emotional life improves with
age.
Here are recent findings from a Gallup
Poll conducted in 2011
comparing people from 18 to 85, and their
responses on a question.
How much stress did you experience
yesterday?
These are yesterday interviews.
And you see precipitous drop in older
people as compared to younger.
How much worry?
How much anger?
And across all different negative emotions
you see reductions
the older people are, in their responses
to that question.
Now, we worried in my research group,
we've done some work like this too.
This is called a cross-sectional study.
We're comparing people at one single point
in time, of different ages.
And you always worry with findings like
that is that it may not have
something to do with aging so much.
It might be that you're comparing
different generations.
So maybe the greatest generation is and
always was the greatest generation,
you know, and they're doing fine but it
doesn't mean necessarily that
younger people today can anticipate better
emotional functioning.
But over a decade ago my group began a
longitudinal study with an approach we
call experience sampling.
People carry a pager and five times a day
we page them at random times and they tell
us the degree to which their feet, feeling
each of 19 different emotions.
[LAUGH] And we chart this over the years.
[LAUGH] And what we see, is something that
looks very much like that.
Within individuals, it looks like
emotional lives improved.
Again, this is a great resource for
societies.
Having emotionally stable,
relatively positively balanced, emotional
lives, it's terrific.
You know, you think of the kinds of
challenges that we face at this point in
history and having some of those folks in
the population is a very good thing.
Well, what about health?
What about physical health?
When demographers first realized just how
big these changes were,
they were terrified.
They were worried that we'd created a
monster of sorts.
That is, people were going to live longer
but they would be infirm longer.
And the good news is, that doesn't seem to
have happened.
The, most of the added years in adulthood
are healthy years.
This is a slide from a colleague of mine,
John Shoven, who is an economist here
at Stanford and has argued that we've been
measuring age the wrong way.
We've been measuring it as how many years
since you were born.
And another way to think about age is how
many years do you have left.
And if we think about it that way, well,
for
one he says that social security and the
medicare problems are solved.
So, so, so we, we, we, could readjust how,
how, how we measure age.
How we think about life.
And do you know how people say these days
that 60 is the new 40?
Well, here's the thing.
65 really is the new 59.
[LAUGH] Here are these data.
So, John says, let's not decide-
Let, let's not decide if people are old or
not based on how long they've,
it's been since they were born, let's
think about what the mortality risk is.
So at what age do you reach
the odds of dying are one in a 100, two in
a 100, four in a 100.
And basically what John says is, when your
mortality risk hits 2% that is
you've got a 2% chance of dying in the
next year, we'll call you old.
[LAUGH] But what you see is that over
historical time-
Now keep in mind this is not age down here
on the x axis this time,
this is historical time.
And people are not reaching that age until
increasingly later in life.
It looks like we've pushed out the health,
poor health, or
health problems, farther into the future.
Now we have a lot more work to do to
compress morbidity at the end.
But it is not the case that the added
years in
adulthood are added years of illness.
We worry about the next generations coming
up.
We worry about the boomers because we're
seeing more obesity and
sedentary behavior, more chronic diseases.
There're not guarantees that this is gonna
continue, but
over the last 50 years, you know, if you
take the long view,
there's no question that health has been
improving.
Education matters and it matters a lot.
[LAUGH] There's good news and bad news in
this slide but let me walk you through it.
What you're seeing on the y axis here is
the proportion of
people at different ages who have physical
limitations.
Functional limitations, that is, they
can't do things in life.
So we can talk about health in a lot of
different ways.
We could talk about it in terms of
mortality risk, as John Shoven is doing.
We could say how many diseases or
diagnoses do you have?
Or we can say, how well can you live your
life?
So what you see represented here are the
proportion of people at different ages,
who say yes to all the following four
questions.
Things like can you go up a couple flights
of stairs without any problem?
Can you pay your own bills?
You live independently in your own house?
You know, basically people are saying,
I don't have any problem in living my own
life, on my own terms.
So that's what you're seeing charted here,
by age.
You're also seeing it in different colors,
illustrated by education level.
And this is a really important story.
What you see is that in the 30s,
you don't see a lot of difference across
these different education groups.
Basically everybody's relatively healthy,
regardless of education level in their
30's.
And people start to get sick again 85 and
beyond, and
we think that's because people do get sick
and die.
So far, 100%.
[LAUGH] So, what you see in middle though,
is this big dif, distribution.
And what you're seeing here, if you look
at the red line, people with,
with high levels of education in society.
Their functional health, the majority of
people say 80% of
people in their 70s, 80% are doing just
fine!
This is huge.
This means that it's possible to grow old
well, in terms of physical health.
The bad news in the slide [LAUGH] is that
the majority of people in
this country don't have high levels of
education.
So, it's sobering in some ways to see this
steady decline in functional ability,
and people with less than a high school
education, or
little education, because this is the
country we're living in.
But it, it shows us how important
education is, and
should inspire us to see that ageing well
is possible.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
We believe that the Center on Longevity
that,
to the extent that the majority of people
arrive at old age mentally sharp,
physically fit, and financially secure
societies will thrive.
And that is our aim.
So we have three research divisions.
One on mind, one on mobility, one on
financial security.
And we are doing our best to apply the
best of science and
technology, so that we can improve
functioning in those three domains.
We think of them as three legs of a stool.
And if any one of them is missing, we're
in trouble.
But if we can get those, those three legs
giving us steady support,
aging societies can thrive.
And you know, the really good news today
is that we're living at a time in history,
as this life expectancy's going up,
we're living at a time when the potentials
of science are truly breathtaking.
I mean, just last week,
Rudy Tanzi at Harvard, reported in an
article published in Nature,
that he had developed a way to use stem
cells to grow into human brain cells.
And he could then implant the DNA
associated with Alzheimer's disease and
watch the disease unfold with great speed.
What this means is that we'll be able to
have drug trials occur far faster
than they have been in recent years.
It's one sign of a kind of hope that we'll
find a cure for
some of these pernicious diseases that rob
so many people of their own quality of
life, along with the quality of life of
their families.
And technology?
Well here we are in Silicon Valley,
we know the potentials of technology are
extraordinary.
I'm gonna give you one example of a
technological advance that
was developed by a biomechanical engineer
here at Stanford and
is affiliated with our center.
His name is Tom Andriacki.
He's been studying Gate for many years.
And what he's observed is that people,
humans tend to walk in a particular way,
and what happens is we put our weight
primarily on the medial knee and
that's where most people develop
osteoarthritis.
Age related osteoarthritis.
And over the years, after he'd studied
this and
studied this he thought, you know, we
should be able to shift this gait.
And he and his students and
colleagues began working on what is called
a variable stiffness sole.
And the sole can be put into virtually any
shoe, and it shifts the weight of your
gait away from the medial knee, in a way
that is subjectively indistinguishable.
I mean, you can't tell that it's doing any
of this.
And in Tom's work, he's shown that this
reduces the development of osteoarthritis,
and also relieves pain in the joint
immediately.
So Tom came over and talked to us at the
center and,
you know, we said things to him like,
that's not pretty, that shoe.
[LAUGH] And
Jane Fonda who is on our advisory council,
looked at the shoe and she went, no.
[LAUGH] And she starts talking to Stuart
Weismann.
The women in this room know who Stuart
Weismann is.
And says, you know, we gotta get prettier
shoes and we're still working on
really pretty ones, but at least we've got
one that looks better and
is available today in the Walking
Company's store.
So you can get this shoe.
It's referred to as the Standford shoe.
Or the ABEO shoe.
But this is the kind of product that we
believe can come from technological
developments and advances and really
improve quality of life.
We think of this as just one example and
I offer it to you as the kind of example
that if we can bring and
distribute these kinds of products into
the culture broadly,
just like electricity, and refrigeration,
and, and the systematic disposal of waste.
Those kinds of changes that our ancestors
made 100 years ago,
then we can use this gift of longer years
really to have more
time to chase our dreams and spend with
our loved ones and, and pursue our goals.
In fact, we think that these added years
of life may for
the first time give us the opportunity to
redesign life altogether.
This is the model of life that we live
today.
And it's a model of life parsed by age,
where you get your education early life,
you work really, you work like a dog in
the middle of life basically, you know,
and take care of kids and often older
relatives at the same time.
And then eventually, you retire from work
and you get a little leisure.
That's our model today.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And it works for 50.
[LAUGH] If life expectancy is 50 years,
it's not a bad model.
But we've now got the opportunity to have
very different models.
People are gonna work longer.
You think we'll be stretching out work.
We could also stretch out leisure, so you
don't have to wait to 65 and
retirement in order to get a break.
We can have education begin in early
adulthood, and
continue all the way through.
Phil Pizzo, who many of you know as the
Dean of Stanford Medical School.
When he stepped down a, a year ago, came
to the Center on Longevity, and
he embarked on a new project called the
Distinguished Careers Institute,
where he is bringing back a class of
people from mid career and
late career back to Stanford for a year,
as students.
That’s the kind of model.
A model of education where universities
have revolving doors, and
people do come early and then they come
back, and they leave and
they come back, and they leave and they
come back.
These are the kinds of new models that
will change the culture.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So thank you for your interest in, in
longevity.
I am going to stop and turn things over to
my colleague Ken Smith,
who's gonna talk some about the Mobility
Division and
the kinds of exciting work that's going on
there.
[APPLAUSE].
>> Good afternoon and thank you for coming
to the, the new longevity class, and
thank you to Laura for that that lead-off.
Always a great idea to put a speaker like
Laura up in front of a crowd and
then say follow her with De engineer.
So I, I hope that I can keep your interest
as well as she does here.
So as she mentioned I direct the Mobility
Division at the Center on Longevity.
And I'm gonna talk to you a little bit
today about what we do in that division.
But then also I'm gonna dive a little
deeper and look at some of the data,
which I think is more fun if we're talking
about this being a class.
So, let's get this out of the way at the
beginning in terms of what do
we mean by mobility?
And I thought this was a really easy topic
when I started doing this job until I was
sitting down at one of the tech companies
in the Silicon Valley and after about 15
minutes the guy looked at me and said,
this isn't about cell phones is it?
[LAUGH]
So I think it's worth saying
that mobility in the way we look at it,
really is all about personal independence.
It's the ability to get around the world
on your own.
To have self determination.
And the way we see to do that,
is we look into ways in which we can keep
people mobile for as long as possible.
And we'll talk about prevention, and
exercise, and nutrition, and
things like that.
We look at how to get people back to being
mobile when things go wrong.
And honestly we do a little bit of work in
that area but
the the medical school over across campus
does a great job in that area.
And so, we find that we usually do our
best work where we are either
looking across disciplines, or looking at
how we take Stanford research and
we help translate it to the outside.
So there's a little bit there we can talk
about, but not as much.
And then finally, there are times when
mobility deficits happen.
People get hip replacements, people may be
in wheelchairs.
And we looked for ways to continue to keep
people on a high quality of life, status.
Even in the, in the face of those mobility
deficits, and
that often times means that we look at the
world around us, and
we look at ways that we can change the
world to accommodate the person.
And, so, you can see as you look down
through here some of our,
our research topics.
And I'm not actually gonna go through
those.
You know I could kinda go through each one
individually and
give you kind of an inch deep view of each
thing that we're doing at the center.
But I thought it might be more interesting
to take a little bit of a deeper dive into
one topic, show you a little bit of data,
and
also maybe tell the story of how the
research that goes on at Stanford and
elsewhere, together with the mission that
we've laid out, helps to
inform the choices that we make, the
things that we work on and where we go.
So we're gonna talk today-
[CROSSTALK] About about activity and
fitness.
And I'd suspect most of you have heard
talks about fitness and exercise, and
I'm hoping that this is a little bit of an
exercise 2.0 talk,
that's maybe different than the the
standard.
So, I'm gonna start with an assumption
here.
Is there anybody in the audience who would
like to raise their hand and
convince me that exercise is bad for you?
Okay good.
So we've eliminated that debate and we've
now gone over about 30 years of research.
And we can, I think, all start from the
same grounding here,
in that one of the more reliable findings
across across medical research is
that exercise and fitness levels are good
for people in just a multitude of ways.
And certainly, when you think about people
and aging, you start to
think about chronic diseases, and there's
a whole list of chronic diseases.
Cancer, diabetes, stroke, heart disease,
that are all very positively correlated
with levels of fitness.
Increasingly over, maybe the last ten
years, it's become more evident that
those levels of fitness are also
correlated with good cognitive results.
And that exercise has in fact, in some
studies been shown to be as positive,
or to be as good as pharmaceuticals in
treating depression.
We see a high correlation of people who
are fit,
with reduced instances of dementia.
And even, even Alzheimer's, that Laura
mentioned.
Doctor Frank Longo, who was over at the
medical school, and really one of
the top Alzheimer's researchers anywhere,
spoke at our design challenge last spring
went through a whole host of data about
Alzheimer's and about possible cures.
And at the end, he said.
And by the way, there is, as of this
point, one treatment that is actually been
scientifically shown to be correlated to
reduced instance of Alzheimer's.
It's a drug that's absolutely free.
It's available to everybody in society and
we can't get anybody to take it, [LAUGH]
and, it's exercise.
And really right now that is the, the one
the one finding for
Alzheimer's that I think people tend to
agree on.
So, I'm gonna try to tell a little bit of
a story now,
about where fitness research is going and
then where by extension some
of the work that we're doing at the Center
on Longevity is gonna go.
And I’m gonna start with how we might find
a problem.
So, Uri Ladabaum is a Gastroenterologist
and
a Professor of Medicine at Stanford, and
he published a study in the spring,
and as Gastroenterologists are tending to
do, he looked at obesity.
And, so he took a bunch of data from
something called the NHANES study, which
is a National Health and Nutrition Survey,
and looked at self reports from people
about how much exercise they got, as well
as how many calories they were taking in.
And being a guy that cared about belly fat
and things that like, he was looking to
see if he could find reasons for why
people were getting more and more obese.
And you may in fact have seen some of this
work that came out last spring,
I guess March.
And the press picked it up and plastered
all these headlines out there that says,
exercise is more important than diet and
preventing obesity.
Which if you go back to the source, Uri
tells you is patently incorrect.
So the press got it wrong on this one.
And if fact it's a very very complicated
in combination between the two.
And I don't think anybody right now claims
that they understand the answer
to that question.
But, what came out of the study that
really leaped off the page to us,
was this this reported data about how much
physical activity people were
getting in their leisure time.
So what I'm showing here are for women
over 18, women over 65,
but really, you can look across men,
you can look across different ethnicities,
doesn't really matter what the cohort is.
This data looks pretty much the same.
And they broke it down into saying, did
you get the ideal amount of exercise?
So, the kind of thing that would be
recommended by like the American College
of Sports Medicine.
Did you get intermediate exercise?
So basically some exercise, or did you get
nothing?
And what you see here in the blue data,
is what was recorded back in a window
between 1988 and 1994.
What you see in the orange data is what's
being recorded in 2009 and 2010.
So the upshot here is that over twice as
many people, in this particular cohort,
but it holds pretty much across,
are responding that they're getting no
exercise whatsoever.
So that's, you know,
two to three times, right, of the number
of people across the population.
And, you know, that's a huge number, so
that jumps out at us and
we say well, you know, we should maybe pay
some attention to that.
Now, why should we pay attention to that?
So there's, there's a lot of papers, as I
mentioned,
about linking chronic disease with with
fitness.
But, I pulled these two charts off of the
website for
the Center of Disease Control, actually
off of different places.
And I thought a picture was worth a
thousand words in this case.
What you see on the right here are people
reporting,
sort of the percentage of the population
that is reporting no physical activity,
in the darker colors are higher rates of
inactivity, so less exercise.
On the right, it's the quartiles of the
country broken out in terms of rates of
chronic disease, and when you overlay
those two, it's striking.
So, I think if you live in the US,
particularly if you live in
the south apparently, you should care
pretty deeply about physical inactivity.
And you know, the amount of, the quality
of life degradations that would go
along with this are huge for our
population as a whole.
So now we as a center look at that and say
well,
you know, if the problem isn't that we
gotta go get people to run marathons.
That we need to get people to get up from
in front of the TV and do something.
Okay, now we're talking about a problem a,
a problem that maybe we can take a look at
and start to, to make some impact.
So, that kind of leads to the next
question, is if we don't need people to
run marathons, how much do we need people
to exercise?
And this data was not, did not come from
Stanford,
came from the place called the Pennington
Biomedical Research Center in Baton Rouge.
May not be a household word but these
folks have been doing some of the better
exercise physiology work since I think
they were founded in 1980.
And what this shows without trying to go
into all of the lines here,
is both the top and the bottom graphs are
talking about rates of mortality.
So once again we're talking about what's
your chance of dying.
And on the top, it's basically due to
anything.
On the bottom graph, it's due just to to
heart disease.
Cardiovascular problems.
And what you're seeing as you go from left
to right on this graph, is the group, and
this was over 55,000 individuals, so it's,
it's not a small study.
Looking at by quintiles how much exercise
people are getting.
And the various lines mean different
things.
And these are runners by the way.
So we're talking specifically about how
much people are running.
And, you know, one line is about how long
you run, how far, how fast, how often.
But as it turns out, it doesn't matter all
that much in terms of,
as long as you're getting a certain amount
of running in in the week,
the drop in mortality rate happens and it
happens really quickly.
The biggest drops that you see up there
are between doing nothing and
the bottom 20% of the population.
Now in fact this study is not without
controversy as people at
Stanford have let me know if I talk about
this study.
We have some great exercise physiology
researchers at Stanford,
and they've pointed out that the right
hand of that graph
doesn't necessarily correlate with what we
know.
We know that if you do, say,
more running, that your cardiovascular
health gets better.
When your cardiovascular health gets
better, you got less of a chance of dying.
So, I would say, if you took the middle of
that graph and look to the right.
That's controversial.
If you take the middle of the graph and
you look to the left if not, and
everybody would agree with that piece of
it.
So now we've said we have a big problem,
the problem is people don't do things.
And you really don't have to do all that
much.
So this is that bottom quintile is
equivalent roughly 10 minutes
a day of running.
And it really doesn't matter kinda how
many days a week you run.
It's just, sort of, are you getting your
15 minutes of running in per week?
That's a big number.
I mean, I'm sorry, a small number having a
big impact.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So when I show this, most people
immediately respond, oh God,
do I have to run?
I hate to run.
Please don't make me run.
and, and people and really, I think,
everybody would agree.
You could replace running with swimming or
biking or any, any vigorous exercise.
But most people wanna know about walking.
And this data is actually some work that
was done in Taiwan to
look at the equivalency between running
and walking.
So if you're going to go out and do a
walk.
And you're worried about that ten minutes
of running a day you maybe don't
wanna run ten min, walk ten minutes, you
probably wanna walk 25 or 30 minutes.
The good side of that is that, and
again, we're looking at mortality
reduction again.
The good news is, you can get there by
walking.
You may have to spend a little bit more
time on it.
So that's where we stand in terms of
exercise and the research there.
Now I wanna layer on top of that, an
opportunity that we're seeing, and
in this case, this is an opportunity that
isn't so much being led my academia,
although their is certainly a lot of good
work going on there.
But I would say that this is one where
industry is probably ahead of academia,
and that's in this area of, of data
acquisition.
And how do you acquire data about yourself
and
particularly about the activities that you
do during a day?
So some of you may have seen these.
That's the Fitbit on the left or
the Nike FuelBand in the middle or a
pedometer on the right.
And a lot of people now are able to get
individualized data on themselves and
start to personalize how they think about
their own activity.
So, last year I had the opportunity to go
to the Consumer Electronics Show in
Las Vegas and part of my goal there was to
see what was being done in the space.
And you know those are the kinda things
that I had heard about.
Well it turned out that there was about
three or
four aisles of company's doing this in one
way or another.
Now a lot of this data is kind of the same
data over and over again.
A lot of it's accelerometer data,
basically how much movement do you get in
general and cutoff rates.
But there's another level of these coming
down the road.
In fact, some of them have just launched
in the last few weeks that measure things
like heart rate skin moisture level, how
much are you sweating sleep quality.
And so, we had this really increasing
ability to
acquire personal data on people.
In fact, there's a post doc researcher
here at Standford,
Mary Rosenbarger, who's over in the
Psychology Department, that's been
trying to kinda keep a handle on this, and
track which devices are good for what.
And I had a chat with her a few weeks ago
and she said I'm drowning here.
Since spring, there's been 40 new devices
launched in this category.
So, if you start to think about, how do
you get people to exercise,
how much do you have to exercise, now
you've got some tools to start reporting.
We aren't at the end of the story here.
We're kind of at the beginning, but we
think we have the basis to
actually start looking at, how do you
actually get people to do stuff?
And I think that's where the really
interesting work is gonna come
over the next year or two.
And we're doing a couple of things at the
Center on Longevity that's go,
that are going that direction.
So, the President’s Council on Fitness,
Sports and
Nutrition, I think probably most of you
have heard about that.
This is the group that they kid about it
themselves, about the group that's
having you to pushups in gym class since
the Eisenhower administration.
[LAUGH].
And, they, their, their their corner stone
project has always been
the President Physical fitness challenge,
and they have focused pretty much
solely since their founding on children in
K through 12.
Well, recently they've paid attention to
the same data that Laura was talking
about, and said you know, we need to start
expanding our charter because one thing I
actually didn't say about the exercise
data was that, not only is it good for
you, it's good for you at all ages.
And really the data says, it doesn't so
much matter when you start.
I mean, obviously it's better to start
earlier, cuz things don't develop.
But even if you start later, you're still
gonna see significant benefits.
And so, they have said,
we need to figure out what we need to tell
older people about exercise.
And, so we talked with them and it was the
federal government.
So in a short nine months later we managed
to sign a formal memorandum
of understanding between Stanford and the
government to work with them to help
define what that messaging, what those
programs are gonna be looking forward.
So, over the next year or
so, we're gonna be gathering together some
of the best scientists.
And this is not all about just exercise
physiology medicine, and
this is why Stanford is so wonderful, and
it's a great place to do this work,
is because you go wandering into any
department, and
you pretty much find somebody who is one
of the best in the world at what they do.
So we've got people signed up to work on
this who are in computer science,
who are in communications, who are in
medicine, who are in.
You know, the Director of Sports Medicine
at Stanford is interested.
So, there is a help group at Stanford
that's going to
come together over the next year or so,
and try to put something together and
hopefully you'll see some things coming
out of that, you know, in the nearer term.
Because it is the federal government, and
the contract runs out when the
administration switches, so.
The second thing I
wanted to talk about was the Center on
Longevity design challenge.
This is actually year two of our
challenge, and what we've done is,
it's a two prong thing here, two reasons
we wanna do this.
One, we would like to get some great
ideas, and
we think young people in universities have
great ideas.
But secondarily, we are an academic
institution and we believe that aging,
and aging of all populations is one of the
great tends of our century,
really of our lifetime, as Laura has
talked about.
But you go talk to a designer, or
engineering student, or a, a psychologist
who is 20 years old, and it's not the
first thing that people will go to.
Right?
I really wanna work on things for old
people.
So to motivate them to start thinking
about that,
and really to realize what the
opportunities are in this space.
Because the opportunities are big.
We have sent this challenge out to any,
any accredited university in the world,
to come up with solutions to reduce
sedentary lifestyles,
encourage physical movement and exercise
and reduce barriers.
We give out some cash prizes, but really
the hook here,
especially as you start to go farther and
farther away from California,
the hook here is that we, we take all of
the inputs we get in December.
We cut it down to a group of finalists
between like five and
eight finalist teams.
And we fly those teams to Stanford in
April to present.
So we pair 'em up with industry so they
get some mentorship.
But then we bring 'em to Stanford and we
put 'em in front of a group of investors,
in front of a group of companies.
And if you don't think that somebody that
is in India thinks it would be pretty cool
to get a ticket to Stanford and present to
Silicon Valley, it's a real motivator.
So as you see, we are going to be doing
this across the,
the breadth of the year and this is our,
as I mentioned, this is our
second year and we really do think that
this is, we've caught on to a trend here.
We did this last year and our topic,
instead of physical issues was cognitive
issues.
So we had a challenge for
solutions that would help people remain
independent with cognitive impairment.
And this is a representation of the 52
teams that entered and
where they came from across the world.
And really we didn't have much budget so
we did this via emails and Facebook and
Twitter and kind of a grass roots
movement.
And this year because we know till
December how many we get
we believe it's going to be a bigger
group.
The only metric I have is that about this
year last, this time last year we had
about a 140, 150 people registered for
updates on our challenge.
It's at 550 this year.
So we'll have to see what we get.
I'm just gonna close here by showing you
our winner from last here to get us
a sense of not only the breadth of, of
where things came from, but
the quality level of what we got which
really was kind of amazing.
This is a young woman from,
of all places, the Academy of Art
Institute, Institute in San Francisco.
So here we were thinking we were gonna get
all engineers and
we ended up with an artist winning it.
But what she did was the most beautiful
redesign of a set of dishware for
people with Alzheimer's.
And her grandmother has Alzheimer's, and
she spent a lot of time working with
people.
And so I'll point out a couple of things
that she found.
You'll see, people will look at that and
say boy that's kinda a silly color scheme,
you know, it really looks primary.
She went and visited Alzheimer's
facilities and
found that a lot of times these facilities
will have these very nice plates that have
flowers on the bottom and things like
that, because they look nice.
People with Alzheimer's will confuse those
flowers on the bottom of
the plate with food, and she'd find people
trying to eat out of an empty bowl.
So, she redesigned her dishes so that the
bowl is, in the bottom of the bowl is
a color that, essentially, no food you
would wanna eat comes in.
The bottom, she found people spilling soup
trying to get that last bit out.
So, she just put an angle in the bottom of
the bowl.
She found that people hold their spoons
like this.
So, she changed that.
So, she went through each piece and did,
did this redesign.
And, so we've been working oh, with her
over the last year to try to
figure out how do we actually bring this
thing forward.
And actually, just roughly 36 hours ago
she,
she launched a campaign on the
crowdfunding site Indiegogo which is
a lot like Kickstarter, if you're familiar
with that one.
And in the first 36 hours,
she's now just over a quarter of the way
to her $70,000 goal.
So, we're very encouraged by that.
We'd like to keep following this and the
70,000, by the way,
is just literally to pay for the tooling
so she can injection mold the parts and
start selling the parts.
So, really, this is what we hope to see,
which is to have, let young people bring
these ideas forward and
find a way to keep them, you know, keep
them going forward from there.
So, I will close with just one slide that
summarizes what we're up against here.
And [LAUGH] and with that, I'm, I'm gonna
pass this off to my colleague,
Martha Deevy, and take some questions, I
think,
when we're up in the, we're up at the end
here.
So, Martha, I'd like to turn this over to
you.
Thank you.
>> Wait, don't go yet.
Where's mine?
[APPLAUSE].
[APPLAUSE]
You know, Ken, Laura, and a number of
other [UNKNOWN] longevity colleagues do
these speak, speeches fairly frequently.
And we're always figuring out who can not
follow Laura.
Who can go first?
Laura presents a really wonderful,
optimistic picture of the future.
That optimistic future, the optimistic
picture of
the future is the reason why I left
industry and came to the center.
But, sitting here for the last couple of
minutes I realized Laura starts off with
just how wonderful these new, these
additional years will be.
Ken then gets to talk about cool
technology and shoes, and all new gadgets.
And, oh, by the way,
you don't have to exercise as much as
we've been telling you.
So, I run the financial security program
at the center.
[LAUGH]
And I could probably make my comments,
complete my comments in about, in about
ten seconds.
We have to work longer, and we have to
save more.
Thank you very much.
[LAUGH] [APPLAUSE] I will take a few
minutes,
though, to go through some of the details.
In a very optimistic way, I just actually
looked at a couple of headlines in,
that were in the ne, in the news for the
la, over the last week or so.
And all we hear about is the problems with
this looming
retirement crisis caused by the baby
boomers were not leaving the work force.
We haven't saved enough, we're gonna
bankrupt social security.
And that's what you hear about.
And there's some truth to it.
I mean, we are living longer.
And by the way, we're living longer but
we're retiring at about the same
rates we used to, and this projection out
to 2050 indicates that, ultimately,
we're gonna be living a full 22 years in
retirement, whereas as recently as 9,
1950, we were living 9 years in
retirement.
John Chovin, our, our economist colleague
over at Seprin, our,
my faculty adviser, my program's faculty
adviser is known for saying you
cannot finance a 30 year career, a 30 year
retirement with a 40 year career.
Yet, that's exactly what we're trying to
do.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, I spend a lot of time trying to
understand well,
how do we help people think differently
about preparing for retirement?
They understand, at some level, that
they're more responsible today than they
ever have been to prepare for their own
retirement, but yet, you know,
as if they're facing many other difficult
decisions, they don't take action.
These numbers I've often found pretty
staggering.
Only 1 third of adults in their 50s have
ever tried
to calculate what they need in retirement.
More than half haven't even attempted to
put pen to paper.
44% of the boomers by, there are three or
four fairly well publicized surveys about
retirement confidence.
And you'll see percentages ranging from
44% to 55% people surveyed 55 years and
over all levels of affluence indicating
that they are not confident or
not confident at all, that they will be
able to live comfortably in retirement.
43% have less than $25,000 in retirement
savings.
Now, by virtue of the fact that you are
sitting in this room,
I am assuming that you are not part of
that population.
And 14% of middle income boomers don't
have any retirement income at all.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, in addition to that, every other
element of the plan, so
I am a boomer, I got my first job in 1983.
My first job had a pension.
The only thing I was asked to do was put
it, sign on the bottom line.
I wasn't asked to allocate anything and I
was told in my new employ,
employment orientation that if I stayed
with Zenith Electronics until I was 65,
everything would take care of itself.
Well, I was probably the last generation
to ever be,
last person in my generation to ever be
presented with that opportunity.
By the way, they took it away five years
later.
But we're now thinking that the three legs
to the stool that we assume we have to
have in place to get ready for retirement,
two of the pillars, two of the,
two of the legs are kind of out of
balance.
Is Social Security gonna be around when
you reach retirement age?
Now, this particular, these particular
statistics obviously are for
younger population.
Those in my age group believe that it will
be around in some way, shape, or form.
Though a large number of us are doubting
whether or
not it'll be there the way we expect it
will be.
The shift in defined benefit,
defined contribution plans is really
pretty fou, profound.
It began in earnest in the mid 80s.
But right now,
2012, there are only 10% only 10% of
companies out there offer a pension plan.
So, we're now relying more and more on
personal savings.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
So, we at the center tra, took a step back
and
said, well, how do you help people think
differently?
And I really do have a lifespan view of
this process.
This is a process that needs to start as
soon as you get your first job.
And we think it's a process where,
one, people need to be, learn to be good
consumers of financial resources.
Note that I'm not saying learn how to be a
great portfolio manager.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Second, you need to recognize that you
need to earn income.
And you need to earn income for a while.
Third, you need to save for the future,
but you need to save for emergencies.
Historically, we've talked about
retirement planning as simply the event
called retirement.
Yet, so many things happen before that.
And often, the impediments to saving for
retirement are those intermediate
decisions.
I wanna buy a house.
I wanna send my kids to school.
I'm carrying a lot of student debt.
Those all need to be factored in this
concept of preparing for retirement.
Cuz until you can navigate through some of
those other steps,
you're not gonna think about retirement.
You have to think about investing in
assets that actually will generate
something.
Will generate income at the end and
finally, you need to protect those assets.
So, we have, we've defined three areas of
focus at the center, one is financial
capability, the second is working longer,
and the third is fraud prevention.
Financial capability is really
understanding how to be a good consumer of
financial resources.
Working longer is pretty much what it
says.
We need to think about working longer.
And the third is,
looking at how to protect the assets that
you, that you acquired.
So, the shift from defined benefit plans
to defined contribution plans,
in the mid 80s, led to a proliferation of
financial literacy programs.
And I thought it'd be interesting to just
spend a minute,
kind of 20 years into this experiment, to
really just touch on a couple of
studies that are beginning to question
whether we're doing,
whether we're approaching this problem the
right way.
That first study, financial literacy,
financial education, economic outcomes,
was a survey study that looked at programs
out in marketplace, and really said,
are they accomplishing the goal of
improving the financial outcomes of
the participants.
And at the end of it, they said, it's
inconclusive.
Second study, financial education,
financial competence, and consumer welfare
actually looked at programs and said, are
the me,
we are teaching people certain, certain
elements of financial literacy.
How well are they learning those?
And oh, by the,
by the way, are those, is that
understanding indicative of good outcomes?
Discover that people are learning.
That when people learn, and respond, and
can understand the elements of
financial literacy, it actually does not
improve the outcomes.
So we are teaching the wrong things.
The third, which is interesting in, in
this sort of environment of social media,
and sharing everything with everybody, it
was a study where information was
shared with lower income earning
employees, about what their peers, how,
how their peers were saving for
retirement.
And not only did that not motivate
employees to
save more, it demotivated them.
So, that's leading, you know, those of us
who spend a lot of time in this
space to say, we have to rethink financial
literacy and financial capability.
And, that shift is just beginning to mo,
to, to happen.
And you're seeing organizations,
companies, research institutes,
government agencies totally rethinking,
what do people have to do in order to
prepare differently for retirement.
And what you'll hear people talk about,
those of us who are close to this, you
hear us talking about having to
make our defined contribution plans look a
lot more like pension plans.
Defaulting in, not requiring people to
make a lot of choices.
And so that's where you will see the
direction of this, this area of study go.
The second thing, around working longer,
it's a critical element,
you have got to work longer, you have got
to earn more.
One thing that I thought would be
interesting to point out,
because it's, it's, it's in the news a lot
and
these, sort of interest generating
headlines about intergenerational warfare.
Because the boomers, because they're not
retiring, or
stealing jobs from the millenials.
Well, Alish,
Alisha Munnell at Boston College,
basically says that's not the case.
A study she published about a year ago
indicates that at a macro,
macroeconomic level there is no, there's
more than enough jobs for everybody.
I happen to also spend a lot of time with
a number of HR benefit consulting
companies.
And they'll tell you that is a very
incorrect and
controversial statement, at a company
level.
So, increasing work life, the role of the
employer.
There are a number of people who think,
well,
people really don't wanna work longer.
Bob Clark actually said, well if the
employer encourages it, they want to.
And third, I have to laugh.
I was just on the phone with Gopy
Shalgoda,
who is an author of this third paper.
I was just talking to her about the study
and this is proof where, you know,
I come out of industry and I'm sort of
practical and
translational and Gopy is a unbelievably
awesome researcher.
And I was sort of asking her for
clarification on the conclusion I wanted
to throw out about this paper.
And she said, you can say that, but you
also have to say dah, da, da, da, da.
I'm like, no, Gopy, I wanna say one
sentence.
[LAUGH].
And that one sent, sentence is there was a
lot of speculation that with the adoption
of the Affordable Healthcare Act, you'd
see an uptick in retirement,
because now people have access to retire
healthcare plans where
previously they would have had to stay
with their employer, and
Gopy's caviatic studies is no, that's
actually not the case.
Access to the Affordable Healthcare Act
within regulated environments is
not causing people to retire earlier than
they would have.
So, what are we at the center doing?
Again, I don't have the luxury of telling
you here's the gadget, here's the widget,
here's the shoe.
Here's the, the, the pretty colored stuff.
We spend a lot of time looking at how do
we
make these defined contribution plans look
like pension plans.
How can you include income-generating
products into the plans?
How can you apply behavioral science, to
the process, so
you don't require people to make as many
choices and become as involved?
Knowledgeable!
But not force them to become expert and
we're exploring this new idea of financial
wellness,
employers really are very conscious to the
fact that there are intermediate financial
decisions that prevent people from
planning for retirement.
And they understand that if they want to
help their employees plan for
retirement, they are going to have to help
them plan for
buying the house, putting a kid through
school, dealing with a student debt.
So there's this big push starting with
large employers,
to really look at financial wellness in a
comprehensive way.
And then in the working longer space,
we've been spending,
we've spent about the last year and a half
working with employers,
really trying to understand, well, how do
you adopt to an aging workforce?
One, do you want to?
Most of them say, no.
[LAUGH] But two, they're, they're
beginning to understand they're gonna need
to, whether it's because of labor force
gaps or whether becau,
it's because people aren't retiring.
They're seeing their workforces age.
So, we're about to tackle a, a project
looking at the, the myths and
realities of older worker productivity or
multigenerational workforce productivity.
And then we spend a lot of time in the
area of fraud which if you had
told me five years ago if I would be as
passionate about as I am today,
I would have said, what?
But the problem of fraud and the amount of
money we lose to fraud is enormous.
And frankly puts an older population at
greater risk cuz they can't recover quite
as rapidly.
So we have ac, actually been working quite
diligently trying to
catalyze more interest in researching
issues of fraud.
And one of the things that we discovered
is that there is
actually no good standard classification
of fraud so you're talking to one
government agency who's sponsoring fraud
prevention efforts and
they're defining fraud very differently
than the agency down the block.
And why is that relevant?
It's because money chases the definition.
So, we think we can actually help get more
money focused on solving the problems of
fraud detection and prevention if we could
get standard classification and
a standard measure of fraud.
So, we're not the only ones looking at
preparing for retirement differently.
There is a proliferation of companies that
are looking at banking differently,
investing differently, spending
differently.
Helping you from the minute you get your
first job all the way to
the time you retire.
Government agencies are at play.
The Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
just issued
a brief on financial wellness at work.
This company called Finan, Finan,
Financial Finesse is a company that is
actually going in and implementing
financial wellness programs, and
companies are doing it quite successfully.
So, the world has shifted and the world is
about to shift again and
I wish I could give you different news
than we need to work longer and save more.
But, I can tell you one, the working
longer thing,
there are many other positive outcomes for
working longer.
And I think we can crack the nut on how to
save more in
a way which doesn't make it sound like I'm
saying eat your broccoli.
[APPLAUSE].
[MUSIC]